hello there
Jesse hello JJ
creeper
[Music]
uh
oh oh there we go
I'm doing good enjoying my last two days
off and then it's back to creating
content oh hey Joshy thank you I never
know what to say uh when I'm like it's
hard to express myself in the
moment
and of course my bow breaks and I have
no more other
bows but yeah it was a it was a fun
discussion
regardless do I really not have any more
bows oh my God I'm
screwed I should at least eat something
so it doesn't one hit
me uh black Jupiter says I love Ultra
hand as a mechanic but the world simply
isn't designed to let you use it
creatively uh yeah I I I
think the mechanic itself is really fun
same with the the whole zonai mechanics
and the the the zonai Machinery but
there there's definitely a limitation to
it for
sure uh I'm just going to have to go for
it uhoh he has
something
Oh I thought he was
dead and I got a
bow
yeah I got to create some weapons see
the fuse mechanic is probably my
favorite uh let's
see because at least it lets you like
create cool
stuff uh sorry I'm getting back into uh
into the controls every week I have to
reset my
brain uh can I use
this
um still don't know why this one is not
showing up probably an emul
issue this is a good weapon
[Music]
though hi there uh yeah my weekend was
good a lot of walking with the dog we
took my dog to the
playground yesterday like at the
playground specifically for dogs always
fun to see him run around
going nuts oh a
spear I see a
spear uh which one can I I I don't think
I'm going to use this one very
much Spears are so op in this game
because they're so
fast yeah I think I should
probably
with the master sword I personally like
to fuse shards of the light dragon to it
makes sense to me since it's infused
with light yeah that actually does make
sense man the frame rate is not too
great uh let's see where do we need to
go from
here I totally forgot how this this
part
goes I think that's where I came
from pretty
sure I think I just have to jump into
the the waterfalls right and then jump
and then swim up
I forgot which button it
was oh you just have to touch
it there we go
Oh Yes W up to
waterfalls
gotcha it's actually nice that you don't
have to press any buttons
I like this part the going up to the
dungeon is is pretty fun it's similar to
the wind
Temple let's see
what I would go to hyro Castle to get
the royal guard weapons and fuse them
with lizos parts yeah but that's for
smart people I'm I'm just running around
like an idiot with no
Hearts no
armor yeah I got to go that
way we
woo also almost no
stamina I think this is we're getting
close that's
it oh that one was wasted on
him
oh these guys have a lot of
HP I'm just going to take shelter
here are they all that strong let me see
if that one's
also no that one is weak I guess only
that one is only those two
I do want to have that chest
though there we
go
there we
go where's my new video uh I'm not
uploading this month the whole month of
January is my month off because as a
YouTuber is like the only time when it's
worth taking a break because the revenue
in January is
terrible the rest of the year you just
have to grind out
videos uh
yeah I'll drop that
one that's also nice
improvement from R to Wild that you can
drop it
immediately another
[Music]
bow we'll just go up to the water temple
and then after that we're going to talk
story uh except when you do it like this
only when it's in in a chest
is there anything I can
drop yeah this one
sucks I think this one is way better
right
yeah YouTuber lore yeah that's kind of
how it works most uh creators if they
take time off it's always in January or
February cuz like right after the
holidays that's when like advertisement
slows
down what am I supposed to do with
this can I grab them or
something what I
do let check for first is there anything
else
here that I forgot
no yeah I kind of forgot what I'm
supposed to be doing here oh yeah you
can recall the another ability I always
forget
about that's actually
smart
it's too
early oh no
okay
woo
probably can just Ascend here
right well not if I drop into the
water pretty sure this just not how
you're supposed to be doing it
but it's what this game is all
about
no
oh just got to push it a little bit more
to the
corner there we
go these bubbles were the closest we got
to
underwater yeah like underwater
exploration you mean
I remember seeing them in the trailer
and thinking yes they do have the
mechanic so there's probably going to be
underwater exploration but
nope now we're getting better
weapons oh I remember what you're
supposed to be you're supposed to build
a ramp here so the bubble can go
over
uh yeah can just use these
two well it did work
but it destroyed my
ramp uh there we
go
perfect no
you oh my God
really I'll just make a single
RAB I'll just jump on it when it when it
goes
there there we
go got any spare Rockets oh yeah you can
totally cheese this whole area if you do
have Rockets I don't think I do
no
I had a lot of rockets for the fireworks
video
I think I have Splash fruit somewhere
yeah Mario
Sunshine the lead up to the water temple
is fun but not as good as getting to the
wind Temple yeah it's like
well I do like the low gravity that kind
of mixes it up a little
bit I think we're supposed to build a
rocket ship
thingy uh or just a fan
thingy got to make sure it's aligned
properly
there we
go nothing can beat the wind Temple s to
be fair
yeah I think there's a reason why they
want you to they kind of nudge you
towards towards that area first
right
it's like this game's equivalent of the
uh
vuta it's also the first area they push
you
towards uh do we have a yeah we
do roller
blades
I don't know if I put it correctly it's
a little yeah I think it has to be more
in the
middle
oh well there goes all my hard
work man I suck at this
game
there we
go I don't have a lot of zonai batteries
uh so I hope it'll be able to make
it I have not upgraded my battery at
all who
oh there's
sidon what's
up let's get a good
angle this really is such a strange
Place
yeah that's okay man we all suck
sometimes
yeah that is is
true ice fruit I can just freeze in
there
do I have anything better to shoot at
him not
really is my motion control yeah my
motion controls are
on let's just see if seidon no sidon
stops
fighting
to be honest here's the kingdom is much
quote unquote weirder than breath of the
wild uh in what
way yeah Kera is pretty easy but it's
just so
cinematic it's a bit like uh more fuel
from Twilight
Princess super easy but it's just pure
spectacle oh strong Zone I sword
uh strong Zone I sword
sword that's like the pen Apple
pineapple Apple Pan or whatever it's
called Uh
don't really have anything I want to get
rid of
though I think I'm going to get rid
of of the strong Zone I sword sword cuz
the spear at least will give me some
cool fuse
options do I have anything to
fuse not really
oh yeah I
do there we go that's a good
spear uh oh there we
go hit
record rip sword sword
once you're amply prepared let us dive
in I'm
ready all righty
then I don't know how the fight is going
to go with the MTO
Rock cuz I really don't have a lot of
Hearts to spare this is turning into a
challenge run instead of a story
recording
playthrough here's the kingom weapon
inventory 15% swords 85%
Spears well just look at the range
like when you do the the lunge
attack it's amazing
demon Stone secret King oh no that's at
the
end to think that such a structure was
floating in the sky above our own Zora's
domain yeah and why did we not see it
Cloud
barrier surely that's the source of the
sludge I'm certain of it oh you
think how certain are
you
blasphemy gaming
g the water tempo aing of time was
good it's difficult but it's
good at least on the 3DS because you
don't have to switch between the iron
boots and stuff not you can just map it
to a face
button
sup Olivier Olivier
oliv
Olivier uh yeah let's just uh start
activating
things the music here is really good
though
I'm running out of stuff to shoot at
people oh wow this spear is so
good oh
I was too late on my
Dodge see this is where the game really
becomes too easy I'm laying face first
into a pile of sludge and I can
just eat stuff I don't think I have
anything oh I
do
that's that's too many
hearts that's a
waste uh
fish do I have oh you can eat Splash
fruits right
yeah damn
Tulin I apologized for last week when I
I I kept harping on Tulin I I blamed him
for
everything
sword blade solders blade ah I think I
have enough for
now tul
yeah Tulin appreciates my apology that's
something man this spear is
broken
this stuff doesn't damage you I think
right think it just slows you
down no Tulin don't you dare don't you
dare blow away my
things I don't think there's
a there's a ball
here for some
reason is there also a pedestal here
probably up there right so I get got to
get the ball up
there where's octo balloons when you
need
them actually are octo balloons still uh
still in this game not too
sure uh let's see what can I
use can I use
something water temple was bad as a
dungeon but I like the music and how it
looked oh yeah for sure it just doesn't
make sense for a water temple to be in
the sky oh that that's probably a bubble
thing it's going to shoot bubbles right
yeah
think I can
probably let it eat this
orb eat it eat
it
yeah
are you going to get give me back my
orb Kieran Buckley says I don't think
this game is worth 70
bucks yeah it's a bit of a I I I'm my
opinion on game prices is getting more
and more cuz inflation and everything
people do make some good points when it
comes to like we're actually lucky that
games have been 60 bucks for this
long or are you specifically talking
about just tears of the
Kingdom just like there's not enough
content uh where is the pedestal is it
underwater think it might be under water
yeah it's under
water got to open up the flood gate
although I'm pretty sure when
I let it go it will start filling back
up again
right yeah yeah yeah yeah okay
uh
can I still get C oh no okay you just
got to get it stuck
there think I can glue it on this
thing yeah
the puzzles are pretty damn
good uh where's
sidon I need I need my boy can I call
him not really
right where did he
go
what the
heck oh he's still standing there why is
he not following me do I have to talk to
him
again he's just he's just hanging out
all right
then are you coming or
what that water I I wonder if there's a
way to use it to our advantage what well
if you follow
me is he coming with me or or
what I think not I
guess oh I got to activate the thingy of
course
God yeah the
terminal got to press the thingy first
before I get to explore the
Dungeon I just immediately run into the
dungeon like a mad man start trying to
solve
puzzles it did not work
no too used to the Grind well I'm just
trying to rush through
it Kieran Buckley says I had fun with
God of War Ragnarok but that game is not
worth 70
bucks so basically you're just trying to
uh so basically you're just of the
opinion that game should not be 70 bucks
in general right I I
assume
my
words a beard Alexy said it's kind of
worth 70 bucks just due to the sheer
amount of stuff but to me that that
amount of stuff is too much stuff it's
hard to
digest well it depends on what kind of
gamer you are if you want to do a 100%
completion of this game then yeah you're
going to get plenty of play time out of
this
but if you just want to get through the
story you can be done pretty pretty
fast I'm definitely not going to
complete this game for sure
never I don't like collecting Coro seeds
I've already been running around this
world in the previous game collecting
Coro seed I'm not I'm not going to do it
again I don't think there's even like
cororo in the depths right only in the
sky and on the
surface yeah it would be nice if games
were cheaper it's it's hard for me to
say I don't know how profitable it is
nowadays to to create
games yeah there are cors in the sky but
I don't think in the depths
right so it's mostly just surface stuff
again come on
sideon there we
go
wait yeah I know I was about to activate
it you
dope why did you cancel your your water
power to point that
out well to me like quality is always
more important than than quantity I can
have a I can have a game that's only 10
hours long and if it's like the most
amazing experience I've ever had in my
life that is so much more valuable to me
in terms of money than just a game that
takes
you 100 hours to just to get through
most of the main
story uh I know there's something down
there near the
fire I think I have yeah I have one of
these I think I can block the fire with
that draw them all
I think it blocks
it
yeah isn't it nice when you can cheese
things
uh what does this do
ground
pound there we
go now I can save up on
battery if there's any game right now
that needs DLC it's tears of the
Kingdom yeah especially for the
story we need more
explanations although I I doubt that
even if we did get DLC it's probably not
going to explain all that
much
uh can I make that probably if I use
Tulin oh no I don't need Tulin I don't
need
you I'm really not being nice to Tulin
even though he did kind of save my my
butt
before don't be mean to my best bird
boy I think he is one of the better new
Champions I
guess can I reach that
yeah there's also a chest there I did
not notice
that I cannot make that
though
Tulin is a fan
favorite I think Mo most people just
make fun of it because uh the whole
stuff with like he blows away your items
when you try to press a but that's not
really Tan's fault
that's that's mostly just the fault of
the the developers oh my
god wow that only did a quarter half
like a quarter heart of
damage
Zite is it the ilal to sell mods for
money I'm not too
sure if that would be considered illegal
I'm not going to try to find
out but I'm not a modder
so but I do happily pay modders for
stuff like the free cam and cuz it does
help me do my
work gamer says gamer 1 2 1288 gamer
1288 I wish that Ru had better Sage
Powers yeah something like orosa Fury
would have been
better did you see how Tulin was trying
to get in the way that's what I
mean Nintendo Nintendo thinks emulation
is illegal unless they sell it to us
yeah well they lost the court case over
emulation emulation is should never be
illegal cuz one day the switch is going
to stop
selling I paid for this game I should be
able to play it however I however I
want I cannot rely on Nintendo's
Services being available forever and
ever
all
right wait what if I disable his
thingies
h
and my bow broke I think I have a much
better bow now though
yeah oh I shouldn't waste my Splash
fruits go away
Tulin no
no
he's trying to do the thing
again uh
yeah let's go up
here a new 2D Zelda would be amazing
yeah I agree we need way more of those
and if the Nintendo if Nintendo's team
doesn't want to work on it like the main
Zelda team just Outsource it to
Gro they've built up a lot of experience
Now with uh
the the the the ports and the remakes
and all that
stuff they should be uh more than
capable
uh let's
see
can I get up
here I think I
can if toing Co
cooperates I don't think you're supposed
to do it this way but who
cares
he did I always heard A Link Between
Worlds was pretty good oh yeah for
sure good story
too uh do I want to drop this
yeah although auring of time is still a
top Zelda game for me nostalgia
definitely plays into
it uh well when it comes to forgiving
the graphics then yeah but I think it
still holds up as a great
game Nostalgia or not I know a few
people who didn't play it until pretty
recently and they thought it was
amazing Nostalgia is a bit of a weird
thing whoa what's that thing
oh you can just recall that of
course
uh I don't think you can climb
this
[Music]
no
uh forgot what to do
here
there has to be a way up
here oh yeah recau
again go back from whence you
came
no
okay just
exploring the Zelda games so far on the
3s oddly enough have not gone up in
value even Factory sealed games they go
for roughly
$26.99 on eBay
really
that's not a lot of
money
perpetual
motion okay now we just have to connect
these
two is there something here I could use
a weapon if I want
to
I will tackle that part
[Music]
later it's probably up
there
new perpetual motion on
violin uh uh uh
see this is why I don't don't normally
stream
because group
pressure must not be an idiot oh there
it
is right oh no that's not it
h can I just use my weapon
then use a water bubble that
works that would not have been my first
guess I thought something metal my brain
immediately went to metal metal
things oh there's a bubble
there in breath wild I always use
weapons for
it like so I would chain like daisy
chain my
swords
sideon thank you gossip
guys L Louisa says this is the easiest
dungeon quote unquote dungeon in the
game
I think the the lightning Temple does
feel like a real Dungeon it's not very
big but it at least it has the
atmosphere this is the worst part the
fact that you can just check your map to
see where everything
is it's just follow the
dots
well we had a little bit of a hiccup
there but again they did nail it with
the
music oh I'm sliding off I'm sliding
off
jeez stop
sliding
I guess I'm not supposed to be up
here it's too far
away
uh
come
on there we
go
ow I was reading chat I didn't even know
there was something to be afraid
of stay cool oh my God Kira
what are you Mr
Freeze I don't know if you got that
reference not everyone has seen
that I'm not sure when when the last
time was I saw it it's been a very long
time oh
this
y there you go
it's what you
get Peak
comedy he's shooting at something is he
shooting at sidon I think he's shooting
at sidon right wait wait let's
see yeah I think he
is I'll just shoot another
we did the Smash Brother stab down
air how did you get how did you get up
here
that was great Batman okay you you did
get
it
uh forgot if you can recall this yes or
no no you
cannot every anyone got any ideas I'm
out of ideas my brain doesn't want to
think today
oh yeah bullet time that
works hold
on
no no you you you just got to get lucky
that you
time it
correctly actually why is my stamina not
depleting oh it is just very very
slowly thank you
Manda
sidon are you coming down or
what this guy oh now he's
here this is why I hate AI
companions it only depletes when you
shoot was it like that in breath wild as
well
did I don't remember it works that way
the
world now we just need to use the
central device you mean the
terminal I don't have any food prepared
for M to rock so I hope I can get
it I I barely have anything I have one
fish and one
mu I don't think you can oh you can eat
fire fruit at least you can eat Splash
fruit but I kind of need those for the
fight oh we're just going to have to
Dark Souls our way through this
one there's a chest someone said there's
a chest where where's a chest there's
probably nothing useful in it and I'm
stacked on weapons so
yeah never mind
I'm just going to have to use bullet
time a
lot AB James says I wasn't a fan of
dowsing in Skyward Sword or the overuse
of the beetle item steering all over the
place to S puzzles yeah same here I
agree especially at the
dowsing or the sky being quite empty but
good game overall my only complaints
yeah I it's grown on me for sure
sure yeah you're your companions just
teleport all over the
place sidon pulled a Super Mario
Sunshine triple
jump for this boss fight I built a home
homing sprinkler boss
that is
brilliant I don't have the battery power
for that
though not good not
good he just looks so funny his death is
the worst of all of them like he dies in
agony get
ready
this is kind of maurus mases music don't
you
agree well did you see the bullets
bouncing off of him or the the arrows I
should say I think that was tul
it is everywhere let's to Cle some
away
Oh I thought I got I got him
but I guess I have to hit him
with able to swi
I'm out of
stamina uh spear or something
else do I have something onehanded
that's
powerful this one is
okay
maybe can do something to clear it
away
I'm going to throw
it
no okay it was worth a try if I got that
that would have been
epic if I just sniped him out of the air
[Music]
uh
GG's man I didn't even take a
hit this guy's way way too easy Z is
kapot hello Soul
red that's my
brother Soul
red Dark Souls did well if I Dark Souls
then I would have been killed at least
five
times maybe more and then finally get
it yeah I'm doing good how about you did
your flu finally
uh
dissipate are we having
fun
yeah I
guess oh I was the Dark Souls boss yeah
that makes sense
Olive get ready for the secret Stone
Demon
King at least we're getting some hearts
out of this
Ur us why does everyone hate this game
that's kind of
a OV
exaggeration pretty sure not everyone
hates this game some people probably
do but not a whole lot like at most
people have criticisms but hate hate it
n
Myer I said yesterday I think it's a
solid seven out of 10 even though it's
not for me that voice again I think it's
uh you've been hearing this whole time
there's C certain things about the
gameplay loop I could do they could do
differently I am your ancestor from a
Time long
past I served the first king of but a
seven out of 10 is not terrible at
all we live in a weird time where
everything is either a 10 out of 10 or a
zero your fluid graceful yeah
underwhelming I guess is is a good
word Kieran that that sounds like
something your parents would say to you
I'm not mad at you I'm just very
disappointed which is even
worse secret
stone that stone that you are
wearing yes is important you know more
about the stone and the Demon King we
already know to your other Sage friend
told us everything the war and of our
people no you you don't have
to Elgar says I wish I was a seven out
of 10 yeah me too man that's a good
number in anent even to us the kingdom
of hu was still in its infancy no it was
not in its
it's been around since ancient ancient
times INVU and cutom time
short but Rah the first king of brought
me and five other Warriors together to
oppose
him to fight The Demon King rahu
entrusted us
withr scor like Dio like Ron
James and fought alongside my fellow
sages in
battle however the Demon King's power
was
overwheling robinita says I'm telling
y'all French acting did much better
especially Zelda oh yeah I'm sure they
also did better on Mario realized it
would not be possible to defeat the
demon king
out he chose to end the battle by
sealing The Demon King away sacrificing
himself in the
process so that was the imprison float
goat float
goat some
later another of the six sages the sage
of do you think the Divine beasts were
named after the ancient sages well it
kind of has to now right at this
point because even the dungeons have the
same motifs Theon King oh Dio from Jojo
I thought you meant the musician di that
happens a no swordsman Nam link will
oppose
him we must help lend him your power he
will need the Zora's control over
water yeah he needs to be able to shoot
small bubbles of water how else will he
fight
Goron
iar evil
Returns the story is in concept oh the
the story in concept isn't like bad the
execution is where it falters a lot of
the time yeah for sure cuz I do like
some of the the setups and the the set
pieces
and certain
scenes and of the of it's just the
execution is so
poor there's so much wrong with it
however the Demon King continues to
threaten all the
PIR sidon my cherished
King I'm just surprised cuz the the the
memories were one of the most criticized
part of breath of the
wild and they just did it
again except worse because at least the
me collecting memories for link was
optional and it made sense that he would
or would not do it it's my destiny to
fight by your
side I came here so that I could save
sora's
domain but it looks like all of Hyrule
will need my
help I'll do all I can just as my
ancestor did like I don't need Zelda
games to be like you're watching cut
scenes for like onethird of the
playthrough that's not necessary you can
tell stories in different ways too
without tons and tons of cutcenes
[Music]
angelic Zelda says oh wait oh this is my
new power this is my new
power the music is good
though heing your
hand I sidon the sage of water swear
that I will fight by your
son please accept this it is proof of My
[Music]
Vow see it's a shame too because this
kind of stuff these types of cutcenes
the the way they they show
it uh being voice acted that's the kind
of stuff that was lacking in previous
games like aine of time would have
benefited from that but obviously
technology and stuff you know it didn't
work back then so they just had to use
text
boxes so it's just a shame that it
doesn't really fall like it doesn't
connect very
well it it doesn't fall into place even
though they have all the ingredients
we're partner up again yes all right
let's head back
home we're partnered up again or at
least my ghost
is it's funny that midu ring is on the
middle
finger black link said when he said this
is my new power for the first time I
thought it would be a second cooler
ability but no it's just a
ghost with the exact same
ability Shay says hey monster maze I
just finished my playthrough of Dark
Souls 2 are you proud of me oh for sure
anyone who beats a Souls game can be
proud of themselves and others will be
proud of you
too I haven't played Dark Souls 2 only
three
and uh half I'm halfway through Jesus
that is terrible frame
rate I'm halfway through
one
and I'm about a third into
three but after Elden ring I I dropped
all the souls games and I just went
fully into Elden
ring but I'm currently not playing any
Souls games I'm waiting for Elden ring
DLC and in the meantime I'm just playing
other games mostly been playing escape
from tarov because it's fun to do with
friends I wanted to play multi
multiplayer
game did you play vdis Gate 3 hell no
that game is a huge time commitment I
don't have time for
that I've watched some playthroughs of
it
but Elden ring however kept my interest
well yeah Elden ring is different than
Souls cuz with soul it's just brick wall
after brick wall you just have to keep
bashing away at it until you finally
beat it in Elder ring you can explore
you can do all kinds of other stuff uh
you can do whatever you
want Dark Souls 2 at least has the best
PVP I've never done PVP in any Souls
game gamer 1288 says I wonder what the
performance will be like on the switch
to for this game
well hopefully a whole lot
better unless they just Port it and it
just runs smoother and that's
it yeah balers Gate 3 it looks very very
fun but I I just don't have time for
it
well all PVP can be cancer Andrew for
sure that's kind of how it
goes you're dealing with human beings
other human beings and human beings can
be
[__] they can just be
terrible I had one of those moments last
night when when I was playing escape
from tarov I was reminded how terrible
humans can be in video
[Music]
games cuz in uh in Escape From tarov you
have two types of PVP you have uh you
can be either play as a scavenger or as
just a soldier and you just run around
killing people if you're a scavenger you
mostly try to avoid people like other
players and you just want to get loot
get get as much stuff as
possible but sometimes you'll meet
someone who's friendly and it's like ah
you know I'm I'm I'm not going to kill
you I'll just let you go cuz you want to
get your if you don't extract then you
lose all your loot you lose all your
stuff so last night I had one of those
moments where I just I met a scavenger
as a soldier and I was like you know
what just go I'll I'll just uh I I'm
here to do a quest anyway I'm I'm I'm
going to let you go you you go extract
and I turned around and he just shot me
in the back
that horrible horrible person
he just he was just waiting for me to
turn around and leave and then he just
took all my stuff he shot me and I he
took
everything yeah it's still in it's still
a in beta technically even though it's
been out for like four or five years at
this point but it's still in early
release Early Access technically but
doesn't feel like it
yeah that's not a cool thing to do but
yeah he uh he just wanted my guns and my
stuff so he he just took his opportunity
you just should never trust people in
that game
ever unless it's your squadmates if it's
your friends other than that just don't
trust
anyone
I'm so used to the low gravity now this
feels like I'm suddenly like I weigh
like a,
pounds I think we should probably do the
gudo one CU that's the hardest
one the Goron one we already did on the
other stream once
before yeah low gravity is so fun but
once you get out of it oh there we
go
yeah I'm not doing side missions for
this I'm just doing purely like a a
story playthrough I I'm just recording
cutcenes from the main story that's the
whole goal of this stream
basically
uh actually we should probably probably
go here
then let's check out the great Plateau
for a
moment have you done all the dragon
tiers yet uh no not yet because I don't
have a lot of warp like fast travel
points
yet I find it funny that the gorons get
the drug crisis
yeah that's say something very different
than in the other
games that's for
sure I'm going to turn off
sidon because having two people follow
you around is a bit too
much reto global
warming the gudo are trapped in a bunker
they seem like mild inconveniences in
some cases you
know it's
like like that that was the moment where
when Ganondorf says like oh these
cowards should be all these people
should be cowering in fear I'm like well
why what have you really done that's so
terrible aside from mildly
inconveniencing
people it's not like people are dropping
dead by the
dozens I think that was cool about
breath to Wild Well nobody really knows
about Ganon anymore because it's been
100 years most people who witnessed the
Calamity have died and they all thought
it was
over they thought they defeated
him I should probably go for that
one that one's
easier I already saw a wiiz
robe King Doran was the only one hurt by
the sludge right yeah I think so I don't
even know how he got hurt cuz he's up on
the domain in his bathtub and there's no
sludge
there was he he just doing something
else or was he out when the sludge
started to
appear uh let's
see we should go
there he was attacked by the sludge
like is that
true I mean I believe you but I don't
remember them them telling me that
specifically I do have cold protection
right yeah I do no heat protection
though so during the daytime we're going
to have to just uh chill in the
shadows wait my fox friend
remember age of Calamity yeah I
do it was a fun
game it is sidon said that when you meet
the sludge like
okay
gotcha see that's why I'm doing the
story playthrough because I don't want
to criticize things I don't know or
don't remember
well I mean I do have the entire text
dump of the game so I can just look up
what is being said about what but you
will still probably like it's not in
chronological order or anything you just
have to look for
keywords
oh you ended up emulating h of Calamity
and that that's probably smart because
that game run it runs terrible on
switch they really screwed up the the
optimization for that
game capturing footage for that game was
also horrible cuz there's no free cam
there's no way to just like do this and
just walk like look around you you just
have to stand there or try to hug a
wall what's up I'm not going to do your
side quests take some
initiative I think she asks you like
questions
right well I'm ready question number one
what can you how can you best warm up
when it's
cold stay near a
fire
uh oh this one is difficult when it's
very hot out where should you go to cool
I play bright Sunny
Spot what cooking ingredient is
effective at been fending off high
temperatures
ah wait I thought there was only three
questions where in gudo Canyon could you
go to avoid being affected by extreme
temperatures day or night into a
cave
baited age of calamity is a fanfic but
well written in its own
bottle yeah yeah it is it's a nice
little
fanfic I got my cold
[Music]
protection you got an extra one because
you're so special yeah
I don't want to deal with
that everybody lives nobody dies yeah in
the age of
Calamity well the only reason why is
because they wouldn't make sense as a
playable character if they would just
die so that's that's the biggest
reason they really had to accommodate
the the story to fit the game
play gossip guy says I sort of Miss all
the lava around Death Mountain and tears
of the Kingdom yeah it's kind of weird
not seeing it that
much
Death Mountain was so imposing in breath
well the first time you go
there and you start to notice the
temperature it it doesn't just get hot
it just everything catches fire you're
like oh
God it's just a sheer size of it
combined with the lava and the
temperatures it's it's pretty
nuts it's actually nice to just walk
here because I can read chat more easily
I don't have to
think oh Splash
[Music]
fruits all right we got it
oh he's made of wood anyway
I'm just going to let him float down
river all right my friend
oh have a safe
trip your friend will be waiting for
you why doesn't he just take off the
backpack
huh
all right uh
teend I don't know how to pronounce your
name but thank you uh for dropping by
have a good
one will they ever make a sequel to age
of
Calamity no I don't think so probably
maybe if there's another Zelda game
after
this they will do uh because with this
game I don't really see how they could
do another one
cuz we never saw the Calamity happening
so they they had a niche there that they
could fill
in maybe there will be more Warriors
games for
sure seek the
crystal oh you use used to be an
anonymous monkey yeah I know that why
did you change your name that was a good
name all right let's build a boat
then where's
the where's the
fan oh there it
is
damn that was stuck in the
ground it's good
enough
woo T Cinder is elf language
it
is well then that is pretty cool but I
still like Anonymous
monkey maybe it's just because I'm used
to
it there we
go is Zelda part zonai I guess yeah all
the the whole royal family should be
then
at least the the Zelda in this
universe I don't think the other
princess zeldas are but this one is it's
part float
goat
oh and she's also part partially Dragon
yeah
she's part float goat part Dragon part
[__] or
hen whatever you
want is that a Oh I thought it was a
cooking pot but it's
uh it's one of those
statues that's for the quest to get the
uh I forgot the the name of the the
ground pound
move also part
British fake British she's not even real
British at least not the uh the voice
actress
herself she's just faking faking the
accent L goat is is
crazy I miss calling him
Richard it's funny because back when
uh when the art book leaked most Zelda
tubers already knew his name was raru
because it's in the art book you don't
really see it you do see the concept art
itself uh but it was all in Japanese so
unless you could translate it then you
knew who he was already so all of us had
to pretend like we didn't know who he
was before we like that that's why why
it sucked so much when that leak
happened because obviously you're going
to look at it if you're if you make
theories out like if you're focused on
lore obviously you want to know
everything there is to know before the
game comes out so you can build theories
but so you're kind of forced to look at
it to do your job but you cannot really
talk about it
so that was a really sticky
situation Kieran Buckley says I was a
good boy and stayed away from the
artbook
league well I think it's like if you
don't mind spoilers like that then you
can do it
but if you cuz you know it's not like a
huge mystery he says raru in he we know
he's named raru in the first five
minutes of the game so it's it's not
like it it would have ruined your whole
experience but it was just it sucked
that we had to pretend we didn't know
his name when we were making theories at
the time that's why me and mass Nintendo
banded or Bandit
games like we all had to call him
something
else so we just called him rich
I still prefer Richard well we can just
keep calling him Richard why
not let's go to kakara
bizar
bizar raru had the biggest glow up went
from an old man to a sexy goat Dad yeah
I like his design for sure but as a
character he's just kind of
useless I would even say he's a bit of
an
idiot but his design is really
awesome
it's probably not good for my
shield I think I can just go straight
for reu right I don't have to go to town
first or do you have to cuz you would
assume that she's just always
[Music]
there the kings of hyu have a bad track
record when it comes to being smart yeah
that's true I think the Wind Waker King
was probably the smartest
one I think he probably
did the best
thing he even wished on the
Triforce which aside from link himself
might be the only person ever to do
so
if I recall
correctly uh wait I'm going to go back
for a
moment the temperature is getting high
yeah that's not a good idea this was a
bad
idea I have to cook up some stuff
first where's the bizaar oh there it
is
why couldn't they just wish genon would
never reincarnate or something yeah
that's that's the big
question when it comes to
wishes making
wishes maybe there are rules like you
cannot like just like the genie of
Aladdin like you cannot kill anyone or
bring someone back from the dead or like
there there are rules to it
I'm not sure he
does bring back his uncle from the dead
in the link A Link to the
Past what's your favorite Kirby game uh
Kirby's ghost trap which is a puzzle
game it's not even a Mainline Kirby game
I'm not huge on Kirby to be
honest I played a couple of one I played
one on the Game
Boy like really old school
Kirby imagine a third game for this era
and Link and Zelda end up being king and
queen I'm kind of done with this era
personally
but I
mean it would be nice to actually see a
queen
Zelda for a change she's always just a
princess
how much I don't have that kind of
money and I also don't have any heat
protection so I'm just going to wait
until it's night
time and then hope it doesn't switch to
daytime while I'm going to the to
Town the zai Shrine
theme oh oh yeah I like the
music or it would be nice to see her
actual mother well she dead at least in
this
era but yeah it would be cool to see her
mom cuz she's she's always half
orphan uh there's
town I cannot see
anything Queen con
sword I had to research how that works
with the whole consort King conord and
it's it can be quite complicated
sometimes I never knew
that oh no what shall I do it's a gibo
we're going to
die I'm pretty sure I have fire fruit
yeah
okay damn we are lucky to survive that
if they had the
scream oh no another one it's like The
Walking
Dead take a picture of it do I have the
camera I don't have the camera I didn't
do that side quest yet actually we
haven't gone into the depths at all
because it we're just doing story
stuff I don't think I have to go around
it and probably make it with the
weo we
woo what do you think of gibdos turning
into bugs uh I I like that idea for
sure I think I think it's an interesting
design
choice and they still look
Undead I don't know if I'm going the
right
way of course the map is totally
uh totally screwed up oh there's a can
get a vantage
point it's just that they're so
weak like when there's lots of them and
they're all crawling really fast and
okay but individually they're just not
scary in this
game oh we were going in the right
direction that was probably still one of
my favorite theories about the gibdos
that they're like executed prisoners cuz
there's at least at least a little bit
of evidence for
it it's Mr creepy
guy we should
Zelda's voice actor wait what should
Zelda I'm I'm not sure what you're
trying to say there mag
magalor
man that the Arbiters Grounds was such a
missed opportunity they could have done
something really really cool with that
everybody thought that was going to be
like a
dungeon You're
creep
I don't think you have to kill all the
gibdos I think the the desert is
probably my favorite area in
general in the both in breath wild end
in this game because it has the best
caves like that underground prison that
underground gudo prison we we should
have had more of that like these unique
caves that are
different I think the most unique caves
in general are in this
area oh you said I think Zelda's voice
actor should voice magalor from Kirby I
don't know who that is magalor but
sure yeah the arbitus grounds were
amazing in Twilight
Princess gosu guys the eighth heroin
side quest no no we don't talk about
that
we don't talk about
that I want to check actually I think
they retconed one of the skills that
they supposedly
had yeah okay okay okay okay I know
where she is I think it's her
right
see this is the kind of stuff that's
cool like I I like playing archaeologist
in in Zelda
games seven heroins who protect the gudo
their secret will be expressed on six
St is that how you say it
St that's for the over there on the
right it says the seven heroins of re
blah blah
blah I doubt you know this being a high
and V we talked about this in the
previous game we solved the riddle
together kind of not really but it's
been five years I
guess they are said to have protected
and guided our people in times P it
should have why does it say seven sages
on
it
sorry this is probably this is going to
take up at least a third of my video
it's got it's all going to be about the
eighth
[Music]
heroin some arue
blah does she say anything about their
abilities
does she say
anything maybe that's like halfway
through the
quest I don't have have the picture
thingy
so the
camera
is Zelda better than Final Fantasy I
think so
yes I think uh Zelda is more consistent
than Final Fantasy there are some
terrible Final Fantasy
games 10
to uh 13
132 thought they were all horrible
15 was
H I think Zelda is more uh like there's
not even if you don't like one specific
Zelda game like the fact that we're that
there's 20 Zelda games and they're all
at
least good not all of them are amazing
in my opinion but
good
that's already quite the
achievement have I played Metroid uh
only dread and
Prime I still have to
uh I still have to play Prime two and
three actually Prime
uh actually no I didn't finish Prime
that's why I want to get the
remake
I was like 2third into
Prime back in the
day on the
GameCube can't hit my mark won't do
anyone any
good I don't think Ru had a British
accent in the previous game right I'm
pretty sure she got that from age of
calamity expect to see you here
here sort of weird mix between British
and American English then you always
show up in unusual
times
oh you forgot the pickles
[Music]
hello that's a great
username yeah Ru became British in the
age of Calamity yeah we call that trans
transatlantic isn't transatlantic the
voice that you hear on those old timey
radio shows like
yesterday the the
that you know the old timey radio voice
that's transatlantic
right we also have a variant of that in
the Netherlands too like a transatlantic
version of our
language this Old Dutch timey radio
voice yeah Ganondorf was great they
should have used him more he doesn't
talk
enough well to be fair in general the
the game is like we like a bit of a
weird mix between not voice acted and
voice acted like they didn't really go
all the way with it you're still reading
text boxes most of the time and most of
the NPCs are
just reused voices like there's at least
10 characters that have the same voice
as the creepy guy what's his name
again the guy we just saw
forgot his name something with a
B boai yeah that's it I was like Bozo
but that that's like maybe that's what
it based on the word Bozo because that's
like a negative thing to say to someone
right if you call someone a bozo yeah
the one that gives you the the boots in
breath of the
wild yeah that
guy the creepy guy that's just what I
call him boo
boai
okay oh I should shoot higher I
guess sh aim for The Rock
right
yes
yes he's 35 and single just like
tingle I think she he calls you a boot
monster
too
maybe we should just finish up this
uh like over the course of this stream
we should just finish up this part so I
can
uh like the the these streaming sessions
in general I mean I'm not going to beat
the lightning lightning Temple today
because I still got to walk my dog
soon but uh we should probably just
finish this
up and then we'll go over the story
itself because then it's all fresh in in
my mind like because I do have my notes
here like I'm just going to go character
by character like all the key characters
that we meet and
just list of what what they know
exactly like this is the first part of
the script that I'm writing right now
I'm not going to show that because I do
want to at least have somewhat of
a
surprise but I'm just going to go
character by character and just uh list
off all the
things it's going to be a criticism
video about the story just get it all
out just the whole thing the the whole
shebang there will be other videos too
maybe even before that one goes up
because it's going to be a huge video
it's going to be at least an hour
long but it's going to be an in-depth
long form critique so it's not going to
be about editing or production value
it's mostly going to be me just listing
off all the stuff that I like and don't
like about the story and why I feel like
it doesn't
work
just the the video to end all videos
when it comes to criticizing the story
after that I don't want to talk about it
ever again I just want to get get it
over with get it all out there and then
we can move on to just lore and maybe
even other games
and yeah but it's going to be a story
critique so it's not going to be focused
on gameplay I might do a gam play type
of critique at some point too and maybe
I'll even match the videos together at
some point like just have one two hour
video cuz there are Parts about the
gameplay loop I don't like either
compared to the older Zelda games and
that was a problem in breath wild
2 not breath wild 2 in breath wild 2
the as
well it's the
I have joycon drift I
think let me yeah I have joy joyon
drift for
sure damn
it uh so we got to meet at the bizaar
right was that over here did we actually
activate the shrine I think we
did tears of the kingdom was breath the
wild too
yeah I still sometimes call it that
just just a
habit is tears of the Kingdom better
than Brew well that depends on your own
personal preference do
you value impact more because I do
definitely believe bre wild was much
more impactful on the on gaming as a
whole yeah joyon drift is is the
worst like as a sequel it's much more
derivative because of the way they put
it together like uh like Major's mask
was not really derivative of AR of time
in fact fact it was so different for
what it was I think we did activate it
I'll just go
there I don't want to walk through the
The Fog through the
sandstorm do you like blue raspberry
ancient Tech or green apple ancient
Tech uh that's a hard
one we'll just do this part and then I'm
probably going to call it quits cuz it's
almost 11: I still have to walk my
dog and I prefer not to do it after
midnight my poor
doggo I have a uh labra
doodle I can show a picture here and
there probably I still have some
pictures
here but we'll do that after this part
and then I'm going to go walk
him how are the chickens the chickens
are good they survived the winter once
again so far at
least
Oh I thought that was going to
work oh now it's
glowing there we
go I should probably use my bad bows for
this because I don't think the damage
matters
oh
damn a l doodle yeah but when you see
him you will be like wait that's a lava
doodle are you sure it's
AOS Su to light he's a he's a very weird
Labradoodle but in a good way like he
doesn't look like most lav
Doodles is that
Zelda oh no it's
Zelda another random question have you
also played
Splatoon uh no I'm I'm not big on
Splatoon to be
honest like when it comes to Arena type
Shooters I'm I'm more the classic stuff
with real
guns she was heading directly toward
those like it looks fun but I don't
think I can put a lot of effort into
it we cannot pet dogs at the Stables you
have to pet your dog on our behalf yeah
have you played Xeno gears no only Xeno
Blade all of the Xeno blades except X
well I did play X but I didn't get very
far yeah I think that's where we're
going to we're just going to leave it at
that I don't think I had to save but
I'll do it anyway just to make
sure
let me see if I actually have pictures
of my dog
here maybe my fyon has
some
uh on our
insta I did find one
[Music]
uh yeah here here's
one that was on his first
birthday yeah end of the stream yeah I
uh I have to go walk my dog
today normally I do it before the stream
but I was too busy before the Stream
with other
stuff but yeah that's that's him I don't
know if we have any other
pictures at least not here I
guess I posted a couple of them on
Twitter and he's been in a couple of
videos
too but there's there's a lot of we have
a lot of videos of
him he's so he's so amazing it's it
really is just a great
dog his name is
Dino he's my
boy but yeah he he's he's a overall just
he has a very good
character he's he's cute he's uh
friendly to most dogs almost always
except when it's an aggressive dog
because weirdly enough he's not even
though he's a good guy he
doesn't uh take [__] from other dogs so
once once he had a fight with another
dog uh like if a dog doesn't like him or
is mean to him he will remember that and
every time he sees them he
will he's not afraid of them he will
just latch out at
them so he does stand up for himself
he's not like a
weakling but he won't just suddenly
attack other dogs if they don't attack
him he's he's very very chill with
almost every dog like yesterday we we
went to the dog playground he just runs
around plays with them there like dozens
of dogs there all having
fun but yeah best decision ever get a
dog if you don't have allergies
or have the means to walk them at least
two no well not two three four times per
day then do
it you get a lot lot of like a lot of
stuff in return a lot of
love you had a poodle
mix poodles are smart so and they made
it to 15 that's a good that's a good age
for a dog of that
size well dogs in general actually only
the the the really tiny ones can live up
to by like 18 19
sometimes big dogs usually don't get
past
15 yeah Border Collies that's probably
the smartest dog breed I wish I had more
pictures here on my computer but we
don't really have
them not not on my PC at
least it's all my my fiance's hard drive
or on her video like camera SD card we
have tons and tons of footage and
pictures of
him but but yeah I I will take good care
of him I'm going to walk him around the
block and then I will see you all on
Wednesday I think Wednesday we can
finish up the lightning tempo for sure
because it's not very long and we
already did the bizaar so we only have
to do gudo town and then the lightning
dungeon we can do that in two three
hours and then after
that I guess well at at some point I am
I'm going to be working on other videos
in the meantime because I do have to get
the content flowing again I haven't
uploaded in almost an entire month
now about a month so I I do have to uh
get back to the Grind I still have a
couple of videos planned I want to do
one video about environmental
storytelling which is more a general
video not just Zelda focused but
obviously breath the Wild and and this
game will be referenced in it quite a
lot
uh I do want to do a video
about the languages like the how the
high in language or languages in general
in in the fictitious languages in the
Zelda series have evolved and how they
work because that's that's actually a
very interesting part of Zelda lore like
how the alphabets have
changed and how they evolve because it
used to be based on Japanese and then at
some point they started being like every
character would just have a would just
translate to
English like now it's very easy to
translate
hen and I don't know maybe uh I'll come
up with something else I'll just keep
running around in this game see if I see
anything anything interesting or maybe
something from the older games I have a
couple of videos video ideas that I just
listed off
but
yeah I am going to
go end the stream now thank you so much
as always for dropping by and I will see
you on
Wednesday thank you all
bye-bye thanks gossip guys see you have
a good one